hello I'm officer shelar with Poland
Police Department the reason for this
stop is well first of all you pulled
completely over into the the opposite
lane of traffic turn lane to make this
turn and then you're driving on a
complete flat
tire I thought so because I had
a so why are you hand me your Master's
card your Master Card okay do you have
your license Reg
insurance is there a reason why you have
an open container in the back I
have in 461 I get a second I didn't
know so Hansen uh
uh you what's your Pullman
address
what's a good phone number for
you so do you have a current insurance
[Music]
no these are all expired here's that
back for
you I
myad so be honest with me how much have
you had to drink
tonight I had one drink you had one
drink what was that when was that yeah
um an hour ago an hour ago and what was
it was a wine it was a wine y okay is
there a reason why you're driving on a
completely flat tire I didn't know was
okay did you also know
that um you were turning into the
opposite lane of
traffic I was coming up
here
okay do you have that insurance that new
one are you able to get that for
me I my dad but I
okay all
right what are you doing right
now I might have
them might have what your insurance
cards okay go ahead and grab
[Applause]
that
all right while you do that I'll be
right back with you
okay so I see her she's driving on
cadium way going this way and her left
front tire is completely flat and then
she pulls into the opposite lane of
traffic this turn lane that takes a left
she pulls into that lane and she just
drives in that lane all all the way over
here um are you able to run her through
sfss yeah thank you I'll explain uh I'll
explain later
why she's still trying to to find our
insurance have to worry about your
insurance sorry can you come talk to me
outside hey everybody this is a Morgan
and Morgan legal alert evidence shows
that Google has allegedly violated the
privacy of millions of Americans via
incognito mode your personal information
and data may have been unfairly
collected and then used for profit as
America's largest injury Law Firm Morgan
and Morgan has recovered over $20
billion in compensation for clients and
they may able to help you fight for
justice if you've used incognito mode in
Google's Chrome internet browser you can
find out if you have a claim in only a
few clicks by visiting www.
forthepeople.com
LC gooogle it only takes a few minutes
to sign up and find out if you have a
claim
we'll just go over here on the sidewalk
how old are
you all
right um so like officer Char marter was
kind of concerned about your driving
you're driving on flat tire okay um when
you got out of the car you're having a
little bit of balance issues so it's
kind of why we think you've been
drinking tonight how much have you had
to drink I just had two
two like cups of wine like the big ones
oh okay all right uh what kind of wine
was it wine it was Char all right sure
all right is that your go-to wine all
right would you be willing to do some
voluntary Fieldy test okay um before we
get started do you have any physical
impairments that prevent you from
walking or standing on a leg or anything
like that I don't no okay do you have
any contacts do you wear contacts are
they in right now now M okay are they
soft so you can squish them okay perfect
all right so if you just stand with your
heels and Toes together perfect okay
during these tests what I'll be doing is
evaluating on how will you follow my
instruction as well as how will you
perform the tests okay um just because
you're much taller than I am can we swap
places you can look up at me I can see
you a little bit better perfect I know
I'm vertically challenged you see where
I'm tapping the pen I want you to follow
that with your eyes but make sure you
don't move your head okay do you
understand want to do a bunch of passes
just follow
[Applause]
it
for
that's all right okay you're okay I just
want you to try your best not trying to
trick you up or
anything just try your
best make sure you keep your head still
though
almost done with this
part someone's doing
donuts
I'm going to do the same thing I'm just
going to go up this time so if you mind
just tilting your chin down just a
little bit just a little perfect right
there I'm going to go high I know you
can't follow it all the way just go as
high as you
can
okay so we don't have a great flat area
but we'll use kind of this straight area
let's see
it's a little bit flattering here let's
go up in
here all right if you want to stand
right on the dot of my flashlight
perfect the next test is called the walk
and turn test so as I'm demonstrating
I'm going to get you to what's called a
starting position what I want you to do
is imagine that there's a straight line
out in front take your left foot and
place it on that line go ahead and do
that okay take your right foot heel the
toe in front of your left so they're in
an nice line perfect OH Close there you
go put your arms at your side and remain
in that position okay so when I tell you
to begin you're going to take a series
of nine heel toe steps down that line
okay you're going to look down at your
feet you're going to touch Heel To Toe
you're going to count your steps out
loud while keeping your arms at your
side it's going to look like this one
two three all the way to nine I only
took three to demonstrate but you'll
take nine simula this is your ninth step
leave your lead foot planted and with
your rear foot take a series of small
steps until you've return on the line
you came from and take nine heel toe
steps back one two three again all the
way to 10 nine perfect so hold on just a
second um during the test it is
important that you look down your feet
you touch Heel To Toe you count your
steps out
loud while keeping your arms your side
and you don't stop the test until you've
completed it okay all right hold on just
a second I got to get my notepad out
okay all right just give me a half
second okay so let's get that left foot
on that line right foot in front of the
left arms are your side and you may be
begin
[Applause]
okay so the next test is called the one
leg stamp so during that as I'm
explaining if you just stand with your
heels and Toes together just like I have
here put your arms at your
side and remain in that position okay so
when I tell you to begin you're going to
raise either one of your legs whichever
you feel most comfortable with you're
going to raise it 6 in off the ground
you're going to point your toe so the
sole of your foot is parallel with the
ground while keeping your legs straight
and your arms at your side you're going
to look down at your foot and you're
going to count out loud in this method
or this manner 10001 10002 10003 and so
on until I instruct you to stop any
questions about that
one what leg are you going to raise
right leg all right you may
begin
are you done with that one okay no
problem the last test I have for you is
the PBT I have one it's the preliminary
breath test does not replace the
evidentiary breath test like all the
test it is voluntary have you ever done
one before ever seen on TV show like
cops all right so it's just little
machine you just blow through for 5
seconds are you a student at WSU what
are you
studying um
kology oh all right what do you want to
do with
that um physical therapy I on that's a
great field to go into do you want to do
just the normal physical therapy or the
sport side of it normal normal yeah we
get a lot of people that want to do
Sports have you had anything to eat or
drink the last 15 minutes okay what I
need juice take a really deep breath in
and blow out hard blow blow blow blow
blow keep going you're almost there all
right so it'll just give us a reading
here we'll review it
together so. 212 do you know what the
legal limit
is yeah so that's
getting upwards of like three times
legal limit okay all right stand right
there for just one
second did you just want me to do the
fields
or
212 um do you want me to take the whole
the thing after this 212 um 212 sorry
she'd be dead if she was um did you want
me to just do the fields or do you want
me to do the processing thing yeah I
can't do the process okay all right so
at this time you are under ARR for
DUI
yeah far too
intoxicated we let you know that you're
being audio video
recorded today is September 9th
2023 it is 3:17 hours in the
morning oh yeah your fancy
ones
all right we're just going to take a
couple steps over
here
okay um does your rear cameras work uh
yes they do okay mine don't in my car so
I'll have to have you transport all
right if you just step right here
towards this rear tire perfect can you
separate your feet wider than your
shoulders I know you have yoga pants on
so I don't have to really search here
anything I did notice you had something
in your pocket on your right side is
that your cell phone yeah okay um should
there be anything else in your pockets I
don't think okay while I'm searching you
I'm going to be using the back of my
hand okay all right there'll be no
surprises I'm going to tell you
everything that I'm going to
do I'm just going to make sure that this
is the only thing in there and they'll
go right back in your
pocket perfect do you have anything in
your bra line yeah I do okay are you
wearing a bar right now yes I do okay um
so there's nothing sharp in there or
anything okay so I have to check again
I'm going to use the back of my hand
while I'm doing that
okay
okay um because the car um is not
legally parked we have two options if
you'll have a seat here I'll explain
those options for you right here
yep perfect um option one is you can
allow an officer to park your car we
probably just do that well you're too
drunk to do that no not me but can I
have somebody do that okay and then yeah
the other thing would be Tony because
you have your phone um is there anything
else you need out of the car okay we'll
have officer shell barer park your car
we'll lock it up the keys will go with
us down to the station um I am going to
because you're under arrest I have to
advise you of your rights okay so you
have the right to remain silent anything
you say use against you in the core of
law you have the right this time to talk
to a lawyer and have him present with
you while you're being questioned
if you canot afford to hire laer want to
be pointed to represent you before
questioning if you wish you can decide
at any time to exercise these rights
excuse
me you uh I'll try that one again you
can decide at any time to exercise these
rights not answer my questions or make
any statements you understand those
rights I explain to you okay um from
here we'll get your car parked we're
going to go down to the station there's
some paperwork that we're going to
review together um and it'll explain the
whole process from there okay um was
there anybody else in your car I didn't
notice if you just swing your feet in
I'm going to put your seat belts on so
your car your front left or your front
driver side tire is completely flat um
are you are you sure you're okay with us
driving
it just park it as close as you can to
here I guess any open spots in this
lot
um as long as you're fine with us
driving it we could park it in the
Starbucks parking
lot does that work Starbucks parking lot
okay she's fine with you driving
it
did you already turn on your rear camera
yep okay you lock that what's that
oh
I'll back up your car so it'll make it
easier